mon
de cheminée alors voilà comme ça
imaginez deux bouts les deux pieds qui
sommes en train d'être réparé dans
l'atelier vont être la partie arrière
ils viennent ici et ils maintiennent le
le dossier qui est où il est un peu un
piteux état parce qu'il a environ 150
ans son immeuble à peu près voilà c'est
un même le paysan qui est en train
d'être lessivé et par le bouïs si elle
est un gros tiroirs où les ou et émile
celle près de la cheminée a fait que le
sel restent au sec
donc les pièces manquantes doit être
refaite un terrain là c'est dommage il
un peu mouillé après tout je peux pas
leur remontée maintenant c'est un peu
quand il est déjà le temps d'exécuter
des pièces un atelier ça va prendre
quelques jours avec le beau temps il va
sécher de nouveau et je mets le remonter
dès qu'il sera bien sec le temps de le
finir de le frotter de le graet et de le
patiner un peu et puis il sera tiré ce
sera six reals affecta restauration d'un
bar de cheminée qui a les pieds très
abîmée complètement pourri donc le
budget c'est de faire du dea turmes 6 et
des morceaux de bois n'a dû voir
semblant et puis faire les pièces
voilà c'est parti
15 juillet 1976 voilà je faisais dans
tout sur la route un véhicule m'a coupé
la route donc voilà à partir de ce jour
là ma vie a changé a changé énormément
puisque je me suis retrouvé avec un seul
bras avant de travailler
il a fallu de la persévérance et il a
fallu pouvoir s'y remettre c'est tout et
puis un jour je me suis de toute façon
je vais me remettre à travailler à vivre
le plus normalement possible à oublier
ce qui s'était passé et avoir une vie
remplie et donc je me suis dit je
referai de la menuiserie parce que c'est
mon métier et de la mécanique parce que
c'est un loisir
même la connecter
decker
mais parler
où
cette cheminée c'est une jeune fille qui
fournira le chauffage central de la
maison et quand j'achetais cette maison
on est venu ici c'était des cadres donc
je voulais pas perdre le volume est
invité sur le réchaud c'est donc j'ai
fait une cheminée avec un ami georges
aussi qui m'a aidé pour les portes et
cette cheminée frauduleux chauffage de
toute la maison
c'est entièrement artisanale mais ça
marche présentant ou mail avec des amis
ou tout seul on voit là on fait du cidre
et du jus de pomme donc ici le broyeur
où sont broyés toutes les pommes et sans
récupérer ici et de suite après ne
partent pas le pressoir houleux le jus
est pressé tout de suite voilà tenir
bouteilles dans la soirée j'aimerais
dire tous les gens qui ont eu un
accident de la vie de ne pas ces séries
d'oublier le le moment de l'accident
est-ce qu'on devra vivre avec ça
il faut le zapper il faut plus basé au
travail et s'occuper et puisse tenir qui
a beaucoup de choses à faire
le
plus gros problèmes de la vie et à la
souffrance physique aux remises à tout
le reste peut faire un petit peu
abstraction et puis s'occuper quand
avant
m
et vous savez le patron joe pas comme la
bête yens pp
suis donc éducatrice spécialisée de
métier et il se trouve que j'ai la
passion de ce métier et que
malheureusement mais au bout de 28 ans
de travail j'ai eu un accident de la
circulation qui fait que je n'ai plus pu
effectuer ce travail et je me suis
retrouvé moi même handicapé et puis ce
qu'il me restait la peinture jeux
j'ai émis l'idée de faire une exposition
de peintures tactile on peut pas poser
comme ça de la peinture en se disant je
vais faire un tableau tactile c'est
toute une étude tout un travail
celui là il est travaillé avec beaucoup
de textures beaucoup de matières
différentes et ensuite affinés travail
et d'une certaine façon pour que les
personnes déficientes visuelles puisse
retrouver le personnage et l'ambiance
que l'on retrouve tout autour
au départ on me prenait un petit peu
pour une personne un peu loufoque on me
disait mais c'était un peu tu es sûr que
tu vas faire des tableaux pour les
personnes non voyantes et oui je vais
arriver à faire ça on ne peut avoir
l'idée mais pour le mettre en place
il faut que ça corresponde exactement à
la demande de la personne qui qui est
non voyante et ans il faut vraiment que
l'on retrouve ce que nous nous voyons
donc il ya des techniques à mettre en
place qui sont qui me sont propres et
que j'ai découvert à force de recherches
en montrant mes tableaux en les amenant
des dents des associations diverses
répondu à des demandes et en proposant
de faire des stages de peinture pour les
personnes qui sont non voyantes et de
leur faire réaliser un tableau un
tableau qui soit à l'oeil pour nous
aussi crédible que un autre que puisse
réaliser ce qu'elle avait vraiment envie
de réaliser de leur donner des choix et
à partir de ces choix de deux tomes déjà
d'en tenir compte et de faire de la
faire faire ce qu'elle veut sans
vraiment envie de faire avec les
couleurs qu'elles ont envie parce que
les personnes ont aussi leur façon de
comprendre les couleurs leur propre
interprétation des couleurs et c'est
très important de les guider dans ce
sens là et de réaliser leurs projets
comme l'entente est pas comme nous nous
l'entendons
j'aime tellement la danseuse faire le
fond et nous tu peux les faire écouler
sur le personnage
alors les boulistes les personnages
voilà wayne est un monsieur qui paraît
chez elle en fait une force qui sait le
faire le tour il est passé chez et ils
essaient d'attraper une boule et l'autre
il est debout et regarde et on regarde
l'heure tout joué en fait voilà
d'achever loi je vais faire ça tu veux
faire ça oui je te laisse prendre
connaissance des deux personnages
comment ils vont être de l'autre côté
oui mais l'un des plus grandes que la
lumière et nous personne rassurante
français ouais puisque sa wii sur le dos
d'accord d'accord
ouais et le et la n va n'est pas de
chaque côté on se sera aussi foncé
puisque là on perd la lumière la lumière
et les opus au milieu d'accueil la
lumière fera mesure ben là c'est dans
l'ombre
le lutin d'accord est ce que tu saisis
maintenant le ton sur toile après on va
attaquer parce que nous le plus
important ça va être nos deux
personnages
si on met trop de détails ah oui de
l'ariège et moins les personnages on y
verra plus d'accord combien les
percevoir
on va faire des mouvements qu'on avait
avec du lézard et jean-marie oui tu te
rappelles que le jaune et en os
oui fait le rouge à gauche voilà le bleu
bleu à droite le noir en a pas donc si
on mélange le jaune du soleil oui avec
le logiciel ça devient le vert de
l'herbe
oui donc si c'est de ça qu'on vend plus
ou moins d'accord cette fois tu es
vraiment tuer va quoi voilà tu t'éclates
a fait taire parce que tila pour
vraiment se faire plaisir
pourquoi il c'est de retrouver avec ton
de voix que tu nettoies rennais chiffon
tu vas les nettoyer régulièrement parler
et c'est on repère cette même endroit
sec et que tu touches tu verras qu'il ya
une différence entre un endroit qui est
pape elle est l'endroit qui peine tu
préfères du foot et de moi parce que je
maîtrise mieux ce que je fais mais ne
cherche pas un mythe à mitry non mais oh
là là tu entraînes que de créer très
bien tu travailles tu es verticale ou
petit peu voilà il vole carrément tué
valin et tu tires de gauche à droite tu
vas ça me tire des effets voilà battu
samedi bien les choses
mais le temps s'écoulera là il faut
vraiment que tu que tu es sensations des
choses à pleines mains et que tu verras
ça te changera ma vision des choses
regardez un peu ce que christina l'étape
est en train de faire d'un call it in
hell est un trait lundi son front donc
sans lointaine puisque le fond c'est le
lointain
donc elle est en train de suivre avec
son doigt de suivre la robe
voilà comme ça l arrange
c'est à petit son personnage je mets de
la pâte
cet état est assez épaisse et je tire
une décote
je la tire et j'appuie en même temps ah
voilà une femme c'est bien il commença à
pouvoir la retrouver après c'est son
bras et dans le désert oui j'ai oublié
si tu me l'as dans son dos le voilà ça
fait ses fesses ces gens à son pied
voilà tu pas là ici tient le bras tu
dire comme ça tu lui valent un sérieux
tu fais glisser tout surtout ta forme
qui cheminait
un tableau de tout le pose devant toi on
doit le maître du tour à tour en relief
pour le retrouver
d'accord on reprend un peu de la patte
de la pâte on va faire la deuxième jambe
et elle est là à ce niveau là je te fais
la continuité voilà ici
donc tu repars à domicile voilà on va
essayer de faire le plus long possible
sans le tronc de casser sa tête entre
ses mains
merci à notre petit bout tu vas avoir
l'impression que vraiment c'est un
travail grossier et patient parce que
pendant le vêtir dans l'est que ça sèche
fera opérer si on retrouvera bien comme
il faut avec finesse le travail que tu
as posé avant que tu applaudis avions
alors on prend peu de pourquoi me
connais pour m on a nos deux boulistes
celui qui joue celui qui le regarde et
nos boules qui sont maintenant poser
d'accord il nous reste à peine de
l'intérieur de nos boulistes
oui donc ton personnage ici le premier
le deuxième et la rue de borda eu
tableau à 3-0 dans le deuxième
ok donc qu'on fasse doucement voilà
j'espère maintenant je dois me de mettre
le bleu même tout à fait prouvé
le pied
maintien reprendre et l'asie tutu qui en
remet bien tu repars du pied tu rambier
tu remontes alors reste sur ta droite de
ton personnage voilà elle alors à cet
endroit il y en a il en manque un peu
moi super battu voilà tu t'es bien
débrouillé va prendre du rouge et lui
mettre sur le droit
ouais directement avec le tube où ça ne
s'arrête pas et puis tu vas car et c est
ce que tout ce que tu sens dans la robe
j'ai essayé de trouver ton personnage
sans manette l'ipap élections il a
caressé délicatement puisque tu vas
sentir dans la matière peut faire avec
le doigté que le pays souffre c'est
mieux parce qu'on a plus subi on sent
mieux ce qu'on fait qu'avec un patient
comme un second père pour au hasard un
peu avec les autres c'est bon c'est vrai
que c'est le sait le tout chez nous
qu'on a
voilà c'est vrai j'ai découvert une
partie déjà tu la trappe et tu as ou le
vers le ciel tu soulèves vers le ciel
fera mesure tu la suit son extraction je
te l'école une petite partie encore tu
soulèves bien le sien dans le plafond
délicatement délicatement super et l'art
moi je vois tant le personnage qui
apparaît sous les aime soulève vers le
haut voilà soulève ça on ne tue lâche tu
te moques pas le fait d'avoir réalisé ce
tableau
toute première fois je suis très
heureuse et je vais approfondir surtout
le toucher parce que j'ai la chance que
moi de voir un peu par rapport à nos
voyants mais le toucher bon bien sûr il
aime beaucoup moins de bus que quand
même que le non gagnant alors je vais
beaucoup plus développé le toucher pour
approfondir les techniques que je
réaliserai par la somme avait dit qu'on
pouvait les faire pendant des non
voyants
c'est pas que je vais pas vous mais je
me suis donc ça me plaira papilles en
fête avec le temps en y réfléchissant je
me suis dit qu il fallait quand même
essayer donc j'ai l'opportunité
d'essayer il ya environ ya deux mois ça
m'a plutôt samassa ça m'a vraiment plu
c'est le capt dany m'a demandé de
devenir aujourd'hui je vais vous manque
et je suis content d'avoir réalisé mon
vieux tableaux et j'espère pouvoir
rendre et encore d'autres
christine et jean marie ont réalisé un
tableau on va dire trois heures et demie
de temps à peu près est vraiment quelque
chose de cohérent et jolie à regarder et
artistique et je suis fier d'eux au
moins c'est quelque chose d'important
parce que on peut démontrer à une
personne qui a un handicap qu'elle a des
capacités qu'elle même ne connaît pas et
que qu'elle ne pensait pas avoir et donc
là il a voulu faire des boulistes parce
que j'ai un mari participe à des
concours de boules
oui c'est pour ça que j'ai évolué voilà
donc c'est un sujet qui pourra montrer
pendant
les expos des manifestations autour de
jacques boulet pour amener son tableau
est montré et montrer que permettra aux
gens de voir si je dis un truc qui me
connaissent si je suis meilleur à la
culture
d'une hauteur de ce qu'ont dû ressentir
à base d'algues et questions ainsi mais
c'est pas désagréable mois mais malia
d'une texture y fait rentrer on dirait
presque que ce sont des écorces de
des corses d'à oui et ce sont des corps
cela est vrai et oui après la vie jordi
savall et là ça doit vous de me le faire
c'est incroyable non j'ai l'impression
que c'est comment dirais-je dans les
sous bois lorsqu'il y avait des bruits
because i sec les et là c'est juste une
fois ça se voit l'amour c'est l'amour
cgc chez lui il est même plus que ses
cheveux brûlés on trouve enfin voulu
faire rissoler l'appareil mobile aux
salles l'éclatement voilà les catalans
de l'économie qui a vu là parce que je
sais les feuillages qui fait passer
maintenant
je regarde la une
tout change le café commencer
s'ils ont du métier vers nice et dernier
classé même si je le touche dénoyage
c'est de là
pourquoi pas
28 100es
s'il te plaît
c'est le rappel oui même sa dimension
analyse de fleurs ou au moins quelque
chose qui te dire je suis non voyantes
aujourd'hui mais j'étais j'ai pas
toujours été non voyantes et j'ai adoré
la peinture j'étais une fan atiques j'ai
beaucoup d'amis peintre et j'ai eu cette
frustration de ne plus pouvoir voir
justement pas moi même les tableaux et
aujourd'hui j'ai toujours ce besoin
cette cette envie d'aller à des
expositions de peinture mais ça c'est
dans ma tête ce que je demande à ce
qu'on me décrivent un tableau mais de
façon très très superficiel et moi-même
j'essaie de recréer ensuite un tableau
de même s'il est pas tout à fait
exactement comment il est présenté mais
loin avec ma vision la mémoire visuelle
je recrée une autre image et ça c'est
important par contre les tableaux qui
sont représentés que je viens de toucher
là c'est vraiment du tactile donc là à
la limite avec cette perception tactile
on en enregistre tout à fait là la
texture et la forme du tableau et si je
devais y retourner je pourrais vraiment
précisément de leur expliquer comment
comment on bien je viens de le découvrir
il est il est vrai même dans ma mémoire
c
la première fois sept en ces temps après
courage leur nom puissant à ce qui
concerne les bains depuis s'est passé
des choses
donc ce que je pourrais dire c'est que
je pense comme nietzsche qu'est ce qui
ne nous tue pas nous rend plus fort donc
en ces temps j'ai évidemment des
épreuves des choses qui sont passés nous
en serons plus forts aussi d'une manière
plus personnelle je suis atteint de
myopathie
donc ma maladie évolue mais mes muscles
répond de moins
mais paradoxalement je suis pas plus de
choses je suis plus actif et je suis
plus heureux plus serein donc courage et
normand ouimet je dirais que c'est
plutôt nos amis des pauvres va linky qui
sont courageux reste ils ont peut-être
moins d'épreuves et ils ont peut-être
donc moins moins forts que nous un mois
- kif mois voilà ça pleut ça que je
pourrais dire depuis le temps que si je
j'ai continué à voyager bien sûr on va
tous les hivers je voyage donc j'ai
rencontré mes voyages a toujours été un
peu d des moments où je rencontre des
personnes où je me marie ou jeu
je rencontre de nouvelles copines donc
j'ai rencontré ma deuxième épouse en
gambie donc j'étais aussi quelquefois en
gambie au sénégal pendant trois quatre
ans j'ai vu qu'un type en couple avec
une petite fille adorables de 4 ans et
puis mon épouse qui est un petit peu
moins donc voilà j'ai un petit peu je
fais un petit peu plus tranquille dégagé
de tout ça une nouveauté je ne suis plus
amoureux depuis deux ans c'est reposant
cette boucle non ça ne rentre pas mais
j'étais moi ou amoureux pendant binger
pas de 15 ans jusqu'à 50 ans donc ça
fait déjà avec évidemment des personnes
différentes
donc ça non au contraire ça me repose
oui parce que le tram ou rezé voilà
c'est ce faire des compromis c'est
souffrir et mais c'est souffrir
donc ne pas aimer c'est moins souffrir
voilà je dis pas que je serais plus
amoureux pour l'instant je voudrais ces
épisodes africain moi je suis retourné
en asie ans à bali notamment que j'adore
j'y retourne régulièrement depuis une
vingtaine d'années donc je suis parti
dans l'idée de d'organiser un voyage
pour d'autres personnes handicapées donc
il ya deux ans à bali gg repère les
hôtels les plus accessibles
j'ai rencontré des gens qui pourraient
nous aider là bas des transports des
visites à faire etc et je suis revenu
avec ma nièce qu'elle trouvait cette
idée sympathique m'a aidé à créer une
association donc en divers horizons dans
le but est de promouvoir la culture les
voyages de loisirs pour part avec les
personnes handicapées quel que soit leur
handicap
est-ce que ça pose un problème pour une
personne en fauteuil roulant le voyage
est alors moi je prendrais le
contre-pied plutôt là contre roue de ta
question en disant est ce que ça pose un
oui ça pose un problème de ne pas
voyager mais bon voilà plus plus
sérieusement indirectement s'impose pas
vraiment peu de problèmes une fois qu'on
a envie de voyager moi je pense que tout
est possible donc déjà évidemment c'est
possible une fois qu'on a trouvé une
chambre qui qui qui est à peu près
accessibles
une personne qui nous aident dans mon
cas oui je dois partir avec quelqu'un on
peut dire que c'est très positif
donc il y avait des participants qui
avaient la larme à l'oeil
quand on s'est quittés à aller avant
pour de famille parce que moi je reste
encore un petit peu plus longtemps culte
quoi donc oui en a qui veulent repartir
et donc c'est positif de même pour les
accompagnateurs validé bien sûr parce
que c'est positif pour tout le monde de
voyager 2 et donc voilà il ya par
exemple
clarisse qui équivaut tout laisser
tomber en france qui veut peut partir
là-bas s'installer aider des personnes
handicapées il ya ya alain un autre
alain donc qui veut partir
et cette fois-ci tout seul parce que le
but de l'association s'est aussi
de montrer qu'on peut voyager seules
maintenant ils ont un petit peu les
repères ils ont des hôtels ils ont des
adresses dont ils savent que c'est
possible et
évidemment c'est moi j'encourage plutôt
parce que les gens partent seuls allons
nous pose la question mais ce que vous
organisez pas un autre voyage pourquoi
ma vie alors déjà vas vis et une petite
île c'est pas très grand on peut la
parcourir facilement quelques heures
donc comme nous on organise un circuit
on va dans un cadre sympa dans cinq
endroits et on passe pas des heures des
journées dans les transports comme si on
organise un voyage en ahl par exemple au
brésil
en plus d'un lycéen cinq cures une
culture unique
donc ils ont préservé il préserve bien
leur culture à tous les niveaux au
niveau
comment des danses de la musique leur
instrument et ils perpétuent ça ils sont
pas comment polluée par une culture
américaine
votre croix et poussé des gens très
sympathiques il ya beaucoup de choses à
revoir
contrairement à l'afrique où j'ai été
aussi sympathique on a des bons rapports
humains avec les gens mais il ya moins
de choses à voir donc un baby il ya là
des paysages il ya il ya des volcans il
ya des lacs ya la mer bien sûr il ya des
la nourriture variée riche et unique il
ya voilà à tous les niveaux ya beaucoup
de choses hein à sentir à ressentir
entendre à voir et donc c'est pour ça
que nous pourrions s'adresse aussi à
toutes les personnes quel que soit le
handicap
donc le premier on a des personnes non
voyantes qui sont venus avec nous et
évidemment c'est le rapporte aussi parce
qu'on n'a pas que que les yeux pour
ressentir en france voilà j'ai eu
d'autres activités et puis à un sujet
qui m'intéresse
qu'ils aient repris par part et en
association à la pierre dont le parti la
fmc de reconnaître un petit peu c'est un
sujet tabou donc handicap et sexualité
c'est très tabou les deux mis ensemble
voilà scellés selon donc il faut enfin
que que le public que les gens ils
apprennent ils voient que les personnes
handicapées aussi une sexualité qu'on
n'est pas des enjeux asexué ou des voix
là et donc parallèlement ce qui se fait
en suisse il ya la reconnaissance d'un
service qui pour exister pour des
personnes qui en ont besoin des dents
sexuelle donc
aider les personnes qui ont peint de 2,2
relations avec d'autres personnes à les
aider à caumont niveau sensuel et sexuel
à les aider à découvrir ça donc c'est
quelque chose d'important mais c'est
quelque chose qui va arriver en france
même si on est un petit peu en retard et
on va suivre nos amis suisses qui ont
remis ça en place depuis déjà quelques
mois
elle est venu dans ma vie m'a rendu plus
sûre de moi plus fort pas apporter
douceur et fier quand ses bras me tient
fort je ne vois plus la vie pareille
j'ai encore des colères mais elle a
remis mon coeur râleurs et tué mes
douleurs s'élève un pays où je pose ppre
aux mmos emma qui me relève me repose de
mes blessures et de mémos qui fait que
pour sûr j'aurais de quoi faire des
démos des deux m'a dit toujours si tu
veut bien prêter longue vie à notre âme
elle est mon héroïne c'est pas la can ni
de la taupe c'est une dame qui meurent
taupe le coeur et l'esprit
elle est mon héroïne celle qui me
surprend c'est qu'ils m'emmènent tu lui
fais du mal men's vraiment rien compris
elle est mon héroïne sur veut encore est
là on paie limete corps et randy mois
record ma de vie elle est mon
héroïne sel